there have been a bunch of stories
lately about internet trolls and
trolling that is actually sort of
creeping into real life now and causing
crime and and sometimes some pretty
terrible things uh so let's look at a
couple examples real quick uh Brenda
Leland was found dead in a hotel room
earlier this month after being
confronted by Sky News over her trolling
of Kate and Jerry mccan whose
three-year-old daughter went missing in
2007 everyone heard about that story
Robin Williams daughter quit Twitter
after trolls posted fake photos claiming
to be her dead father and former model
Charlotte Dawson who was found dead at
her apartment after battling depression
had been subjected to a torrent of abuse
on Twitter this is just a couple of the
examples now you guys are watching this
on YouTube right now you know what the
comments often devolve into for the
record by the way I want to say
something about our comments here our
stuff is actually pretty good and you
guys are pretty on point about what
we're talking about and for some reason
we don't get a lot of the crazy racist
stuff and whatever so for you guys right
there Jimmy you want to applaud these
people yeah or attack Jimmy oh no okay
my breasts are applauding because I know
they get a lot of yeah Jimmy yeah Gina's
breast huge on the
YouTube anywh who uh so some bad stuff
is happening though because we all know
about the trolling um and the fact that
it's actually becoming sort of a real
world consequence now is is really kind
of scary don't you think yeah I I think
that at first you know this was just
like a couple people and you know
everybody says the same Trope oh it's
some guy in his parents basement he has
no life no money no friends well I think
the scary thing is these these people
are among us now these people are people
saying you know what you're famous
you're rich you're successful a you
deserve to be hurt you deserve to be
taken down and B you shouldn't be able
to feel it because all of these things
insulate you your Fame your your money
you you no longer have access to your
feelings which is totally insane and I
don't think I'm saying anything too
controversial here by saying that anyone
who did that to Robin Williams daughter
and then hid behind um well you know
it's My Free Speech you're a piece of
there is nothing lower than what
you did okay so you hit a couple good
points there but I'm I'm going to let
you go well you know it's just there
there's such a meanness in the culture
now it's even hard to keep up go to any
YouTube video click on the fourth
commenters comment the fourth commenter
always mercilessly rips the third
commenter right and then the fifth
commenter the newcomer tries to find
Common Ground between everybody and for
that the six commentor impunes his
sexuality yeah so stupid it's it's not
you know and it's all and the racist
trolling on YouTube and the the people
who are worse at that are the Puerto
Ricans I think we can all agree um so
here's the thing if you're getting you
know God I wish we had a rim shot for
that if you're getting tweeted if you're
getting tweeted at uh and it's hurting
your feelings stop going on Twitter that
would be my advice to you if you're
going on Facebook and you're getting a
lot of hurtful stop going on Facebook
those are all imaginary places they
don't really exist exist you can go
outside and have a lunch you can see
someone you go on to Starbucks you do
something you can go to Starbucks and go
on Twitter yeah so there's another part
of trolling that I'm noticing now which
is people that are public people so it's
not just Anonymous people anymore those
are the ones usually that are attacking
everyone and saying all the racist stuff
and the homophobic stuff but I'm
noticing a new pattern of people that
are public people often it's a lot of
media people that are fighting with each
other constantly on Twitter publicly
doing it with their names and everything
but that seems to be the the new
trolling because it's like you guys
would not do this if you were sitting
across a table from each other you know
what I mean this endless bickering back
and forth and making a point back and I
beat you at this point and you beat me
at this point and I think that's the new
trolling is just saying that you
wouldn't say if they were right in front
of you well and I think that that just
it doesn't matter if you're famous or
you're not famous it's a gigantic
platform and it's like you're sitting
there with a soldout house you know you
have 10,000 50,000 a million followers
so you have all these eyeballs on you so
you might as well uh take advantage of
the those eyeballs because they're
watching and they'll listen to you yeah
so um you know as far as the an
anonymity of it uh Huffington Post I
think got rid of anonymous uh trolling
or they got rid of the anonymous
commenters do you think we need some
element of that because maybe not in
America where at least we have free
speech for now I think but in some of
these other countries where you know
like Egypt where you know revolutions
are started because of this stuff on
social media they need some level of
anonymity right well what face what
Huffington Post did was they decided
that uh you had to have your Facebook
uh right so you have to sign in with
Facebook so we know who you are and you
know how hard it is to create a phony
Facebook profile it could take upwards
of two minutes Jimmy maybe maybe a whole
60 seconds or something so that's why
that was funny to me when they did that
I was like oh is this this is like this
is this is being screened at the airport
this is the guy patting you down at the
a it's all window dressing it doesn't
really mean anything if you want to
troll you can still troll yeah any final
thoughts on this I don't know man and I
I honestly I think in this country for
me I don't think there's really any
reason to be anonymous when you're when
you're being a commenter I can see how
it can definitely affect people in other
countries and I'm sure there going to be
people that disagree with me I just I
just don't see it I just don't know why
if you stand and be count it yeah wait
so I did get my final thought back which
is jumps off that which is is there's
some reason that we need this that maybe
these Anonymous people who are getting
all this vile gross stuff out that maybe
that's actually better than them taking
it to the real world even though now it
is trickling into the real world it
fuels the real world you think just not
I when when someone says something
terrible horrible terrible to me online
I go well thank God they got that out of
their system because now the world's a
more pleasant place now I'm feeling
reactive my prefrontal cortex is going
crazy my amydala is getting hijacked I
don't think anyone's better off because
of that touche touche Jimmy bring us
home I think it helps you develop a
thick skin and dismiss things that
aren't important and people's opinions
who you don't even know so I think it's
that's a good muscle to build up you
have to build it up as a comedian if you
let a Heckler get under your skin
winning you're losing so I just think
it's one of those things you learn how
to you know this is anonymous this is
funny it's learn how to build a thick
skin that's what this and if you can't
but don't read the comments
that's all by the way it is
jimmyo on the Twitter so let Jimmy know
how you
feel